Because the reality of what we just did is so important.
But the truth is that if he only died,
if you remember a couple weeks ago at Easter Sunday,
we said this, if he only died, we are still in our sins.
One Corinthians 15 then says that faith is hopeless.
That what we're doing here is really useless.
It's pointless for us to believe in this thing.
That's why the truth that we're gonna highlight today is
that our God is faithful in victory is so important.
That's why this is so critical.
Victory not only over sin on the cross,
which we just celebrated, but victory over death itself.
And so turn with me in God's word to one Corinthians 15.
We're gonna see this very clearly today.
One Corinthians chapter 15.
Now there, there were some people back in Corinth, this city
that Paul was writing this letter to that denied the reality
of resurrection at all.
And so Paul spent the entire chapter defending the
reality of resurrection.
That it's legit, it's real.
But there were some people who said, okay, yeah,
resurrection's real.
But there were, there was questions being asked about
what happened to those, not just who died
before Jesus would return.
But what about those who were left alive
when Jesus returned?
Because at the time, in their thought process,
they had a dualistic view of the person
that there was a body and there was a soul.
But they saw the body as bad, as evil, as something
that the soul needed to be freed from.
So they said, well, if somebody dies, then their body's gone
and their soul is freed to be with the Lord forever.
That's great. So we want to die
before Jesus comes back, right?
But if you were still alive when Jesus came back,
then you were stuck 'cause you hadn't been freed yet from
this trap of the body.
Well, that's part of what Paul addressed here.
He says throughout this chapter that everyone,
whether you're dead or alive, when Jesus returns,
everyone receives the same treatment.
We all have the same problem.
So we all need the same solution.
Whether you're dead or alive, it doesn't matter.
We get the same solution. So look at the end of chapter 15.
This is his capstone argument.
What he goes through the whole process teaching this
rhetorically, arguing for this.
Here's how he ends verses 50 through 58.
As I tell you this, brothers flesh
and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of God,
Nor does the perishable inherit the imperishable.
Behold, I tell you a mystery, we shall not all sleep,
but we shall all be changed.
Meaning we won't all die,
but we shall all be changed in a moment in the twinkling
of an eye at the last trumpet.
For the trumpet will sound
and the dead will be raised imperishable
and we shall be changed.
For this perishable body must put on the imperishable,
this mortal body must put on immortality.
When the perishable puts on the imperishable
and the mortal puts on immortality, then shall come
to pass the saying that is written,
death is swallowed up in victory.
Oh, death. Where is your victory? Oh, death.
Where is your sting?
The sting of death is sin and the power of sin is the law.
But thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
Therefore, my beloved brothers be steadfast, immovable,
always abounding in the work of the Lord, knowing
that in the Lord your labor is not in
Vain.
God, help us understand this clearly today.
Awaken us, give us joy.
Give us excitement for this reality that is come
and will come for us.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Alright, so let's unpack this passage because I said it.
He's making rhetorical argument here.
The first thing he says is
that there's a problem that we all have.
That's the first question here.
What's the problem that he's addressing?
Well, look again at at verse 50, he said, I tell you this,
meaning listen up, this is important.
Flesh and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of God.
Flesh and blood was a common phrase for the physical body.
And he says here, the physical body as it is,
cannot possess the kingdom.
Since the kingdom of God is spiritual in nature, first
the physical body
that we have can't get there even further.
He adds, nor does the perishable inherit the imperishable.
That imperishable inheritance that one Peter talks about
that word perishable means corrupted or
or that it breaks down.
So here's an example. Just think about the perishable food
on your shelf, right?
You know that that has an expiration date, right?
It will not last forever.
You can watch it degrade over time as that food perishes.
Isn't that true of our physical bodies?
That's part of the problem here,
that we are perishable, right?
That's what he says here. We physical bodies,
we are perishable.
Just like that. Milk in your fridge like we are perishable.
We are fading away. We are degrading over time.
Romans eight says, creation itself is in bondage
to corruption, to this perishing.
It's fading. That's why verse 53, he says,
this perishable,
perishable body must put on the perishable.
These dying bodies cannot inherit the kingdom of God.
So something has to change.
But how often do we want to deny that reality
that we're perishing, right?
Like, why do Americans spend billions upon billions
of dollars each year on diet fads,
the latest workout regimen, plastic surgery,
all these things to say, no, no, I'm not perishing.
Why do we do that? Because we don't want to admit
that we are perishable.
We don't wanna admit that we live in a, a world tainted
by sin and bodies affected by sin.
We will not be perfect. We cannot maintain perfection.
Yet, for me, it's still been hard to wrap my mind
around the fact that my knee is not healing, right?
I can't do what I used to do.
But isn't that a pride that somehow in my mind,
I think I'm somehow immune to this perishing
that I, I've got a, a get outta jail free card in that,
that I'm, I get a pass that I don't have to suffer
and perish like every one of us does.
It's my unwillingness to admit my creatureliness
before the creator that I'm perishing.
We are perishing. And so that's a problem.
But there's an even worse problem than the fact
that our joints creak when we wake up.
It's the fact that we are mortal, we're perishable,
but we are mortal.
Verse th 53, he says,
this mortal body must put put on immortality.
It's almost like he's pointing at his own body.
Like this mortal body has to put on immortality.
That word means subject to death.
That that mortal means we
as this body will not live forever.
Again, we put that off. We try to avoid it.
We, we think we're invincible when we're young.
It's not gonna happen to me.
It says reality. Now, I'm not trying
to put a damper on your celebrations today,
but a healthy perspective in life is that each one
of us woke up today one day closer to death,
happy Mother's Day, right?
But that's true, isn't it? We can't avoid it. Hebrews 9 27.
It's destined for man to die once
after that face judgment, every one of us a hundred percent.
But that also means unless something gives us immortality,
then we're stuck in this mortal state
where death is a reality.
So we got perishing, we got mortal.
That's problem after problem.
But the biggest problem in all of this
is the fact that we are sinful.
Yes, perishable mortal is a problem difficult.
But the worst part is that we are perishable.
We are sinful. I mean, look at verse 56 again.
The sting of death is sin.
The power of sin is the law.
Now I know it's short, but it's a really interesting verse.
It teaches us, check this out,
that it's not death in itself.
That is the harmful thing.
It's the Romans six wages of sin, death. That's the problem.
And you see that here because actually over in Philippians
one, Paul talks about how death is gain for, for him.
Death is, is not a loss.
To depart and be
with the Lord is far better than even living here.
So to him, death's not a problem.
Here's the reality. Where sin is pardoned,
death has no sting,
but it's when sin has not been dealt with.
That's where death is.
This lethal adversary, this poisonous snake
that we can't get away from and we can't fix and deal with.
That's where death is a problem,
is when sin is still in involved
and it's God's law that shows us our sin.
But the problem is God's law cannot fix the
problem of our sin.
That's why the power of sin is the law.
It keeps us trapped unless something intervenes.
So again, our problem is that without an intervention,
every single one of us is perishing
and will one day die condemned in our sin.
So what's the solution, right?
We've identified the problem very clearly.
What's the solution then if that's our problem?
If our problem is that we can't fix it on our own,
what is the solution?
That's where God's faithfulness comes in.
Talking about God's faithfulness.
This whole series, his faithfulness here is that
before time began, God knew this was gonna be a problem
for his created beings.
So what did he do to overcome it?
Look at verse 57,
but thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
The solution is victory through our Lord Jesus Christ.
That was it, right? It was Christ's victory
that accomplished all of this
that fixed our deepest problem.
And first it was victory over sin like we just celebrated.
In the Lord's Supper,
we celebrate Christ's victory over sin.
'cause remember, the only sting death has is
whenever it's affected by sin.
Whenever sin has not been dealt with.
And so what did Christ do?
He satisfied the claims of the law on us.
This is how Galatians three 13 says it,
Christ redeemed us from the curse of the law
by becoming a curse for us.
For it is written curse.
It is everyone who's hanged on a tree,
the sting of sin.
Christ took it on himself.
He's dealt thoroughly with the problem of sin
through never sending himself yet taking on
our place on the cross, sacrificing himself as a penalty
for our sin to cover it.
So he claimed victory over sin.
And listen that victory is not just future.
It's not just applicable to when you die.
You finally get to be with God forever.
Christ's victory over sin matters even today.
Church, if he
released us from the curse of the sin in our lives,
if he freed us from the chains of sin in our lives,
that means that's today.
Not just future, that we can walk live in the freedom
that sin doesn't hold us anymore.
That you don't have to sin anymore. You don't have to.
If you're in Christ who's freed you from that
and he overcame that, you don't have to do it anymore.
He has victory over sin. It doesn't hold us anymore.
Yet, if you remember the passage, we still have
that pesky flesh
and blood problem we saw in one Corinthians 15 that
were perishable or mortal.
We can't inherit the kingdom in that way,
which is why the other part
of the solution here is Christ's victory over death
as well is victory over sin.
But his victory over death matters as well.
And we've already seen it. How tightly tied sin
and death were in this passage, right?
It's, it's what I already said, that the sting
of death only comes because of sin.
Yet as as one Corinthians 15 teaches,
if there's not something on the other side of death,
then we're still hopeless.
We're still in our sins.
If he just died, we're still in our sins
because the resurrection hasn't happened.
Nothing is on the other side of death.
Sin has been paid for, but there's no victory over
that final enemy.
That's why Paul wrote this whole chapter. Go read it today.
Sometime this whole chapter, he's teaching
that Christ truly was raised from the dead.
And if he was truly raised from the dead, that means we
who are in him will be raised from the dead too.
We will get new bodies.
I, I, I just, I just can't conceive of that
of course like we can't understand that.
But verse 26 says, the last enemy to be destroyed is death.
And all these other enemies have been put under subjection
to Christ underneath his feet.
The last enemy to be destroyed is death.
And because Christ has been raised first, those
who are in him are guaranteed to follow him.
And I love the picture that Hebrews two paints
regarding this as Hebrews two 14 and 15.
It says, since
therefore the children share in flesh and blood bodies.
He himself
likewise partook of the same things, that
through death he might destroy the one who has the power
of death that is the devil.
And deliver all those who through fear
of death we're subject to lifelong slavery.
'cause remember in sin we should be afraid of death
because it's condemnation.
But Jesus took on flesh
and blood without sin,
took the curse, defeated the enemy of death.
And now we are free from fear of death
'cause it's been beaten.
That's why Paul nearly taunts death.
Go back to one Corinthians 15 verses 54
and 55, he's almost taunting death.
This saying that is written,
death is swallowed up in victory.
Oh, death, where is your victory? Oh, death.
Where is your sting? He's saying death. You loose.
And he's quoting Isaiah 25, he's referencing hose Isaiah 13
where Paul said death was a shroud over humanity.
A sheet that covered all the nations,
yet God removed it in Christ.
But not only removed it, he also destroyed it.
It was gone absorbing it.
The sting of it, the resurrection,
overcoming it 'cause death, right?
The wages of sin is death.
Death used to be a judgmental consequence for sin.
But in Christ's fulfillment of the law, death now becomes
a gateway into God's presence.
And and hear me, I said, he's kind
of taunting, almost singing a song.
No one sings that song. We are the champions.
Unless victory is without doubt
and secured, like you don't, that's not your walkup song
whenever you're about to go to bat, right?
That's not your, you're going into the debate room
and you're like, we are the champion.
Like that's you don't do that. 'cause what if you lose?
Right? You look pretty foolish.
You don't sing that song unless you've already won.
Listen, in our faith, oh man, this gets me in our faith.
Every Sunday we sing songs like that
because we're great, because we're awesome
'cause we know we're gonna overcome.
No, because Christ has already won the
victory and we can sing.
We are the champions because of his faithfulness for us.
Do you have that hope? And
do you have this kind of hope?
Can you, can you look at death through this lens
of victorious hope?
Or are you still afraid of death?
Are you still afraid of Jesus returning
because you don't really know where you stand with him?
Listen, God is faithful and he's
provided a way for you to, to have this victory,
to share in this victory.
It's Romans 10, nine says,
therefore, if anyone believes in his heart
that God raised him from the dead
and confesses with his mouth
that Jesus is Lord will be saved.
Simple. It's how Paul ended.
Verse 57, thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
We didn't earn it. We can't earn it.
But thanks be to God who gives it
To those who believe.
That's how you can have this hope.
Now we could end there 20 minutes in and just be encouraged
and ready to go and sing and worship
and lift our voices and praise.
But if you remember there was another verse
that I haven't referenced yet, right?
He doesn't stop there.
And this is classic the Apostle Paul,
he's making this incredibly rich theological argument,
but he doesn't keep it just theoretical,
he makes it intensely applicable.
He says, for those who do believe, here's
what your response should be.
So if you believe this, if this is what your hope
and your stance is, this is how you should respond to
that hope.
'cause looking at it, verse 58, he said, what?
What's the first word? Therefore,
in other words, because of all of the gospel truth,
I've just proclaimed all of the resurrection hope
that I've just explained to you over and over again.
All of that, the victory in Christ.
Therefore be steadfast,
immovable, always abounding in the work of the Lord.
Knowing that in the Lord your labor is not in vain
in the Lord, in that victorious Lord, this is what we do.
So here's the first response He says.
He says, stand steadfastly in light of all
of this, in light of the victory in Christ.
He says, stand steadfastly, be steadfast, immovable.
He's talking about the veracity, the truthfulness
of our faith, the orthodoxy of our truths that we believe,
we stand on it.
It's a value we have anchoring truth, we are anchored by it
and we are holding it fast.
Not only past truths,
but what we'll get later that we're holding fast.
We're steadfast, immovable in that even today.
And there's something about future certainty
that gives you courage today.
Because when you know something's
coming, it gives you courage.
Today, I can just imagine this,
it doesn't really fit based on yesterday,
but imagine you recorded the thunder game
and you were gonna watch it later
because you're gonna be busy, you're gonna be at
your kid's game or whatever it is.
And you wonder, watch it later.
And it's hard as you try to avoid it.
Someone let the cat outta
the bag that they had won the game.
You are a little frustrated with that person.
'cause you wanted to watch it later, but
but you see the point, right?
So you'd recorded it, you don't know what's happened.
But then you know now before you watch it, that they had won
and, and when you turn that game on later to watch it,
imagine how you would watch it
A little bit differently, right?
You would watch it probably a little calmer.
You wouldn't be as worried about that mis shot
or that missed rebound or whatever it was You.
You'd notice details about the game
that you wouldn't have otherwise.
And you would, you would know that you don't have any fear
about what might come.
Why? Because the outcome has already been guaranteed.
So church, listen, we know
that Christ has secured the victory
for us over sin and death.
And he said those who believe in him will also receive
that victory over sin and death.
There is no fear.
So listen, what do we have
to worry about today during the game?
Like why do I get so stressed out about
how things are gonna work out now
and if this is gonna happen or that's gonna happen?
Why do I wonder about the missed shots
that happen in my life?
Like why do I wonder about that?
'cause I already know the end. We can
be steadfast.
That's what he says, right? Steadfast,
immovable, unshakeable.
Which means we can take tough news,
we can face a lost job, we can face a difficult
diagnosis, Yet stand
Steadfast on Christ.
And that's not just in our beliefs, like in our mental,
okay, yes, I know I'm still believing in this.
I still believe in this. And that's not just there.
That's in our lives too. That's in daily life.
That's in our actions
because look at what else Christ's victory brings.
He says, yes, steadfast
and movable, always abounding in the work of the Lord.
Knowing that in the Lord your labor is not in vain.
So we respond to what he has done
and what he will do
by serving sacrificially,
we stand steadfastly, beliefs, thought, process, faith.
We stand on the rock of Christ
and we serve sacrificially, we abound in it.
He says, where we overflow with service
because of the gospel, because of the resurrection.
It's similar to what Paul wrote elsewhere.
This is Ephesians two, chapter 10.
He just explained the gospel of what God does
to bring from death to life.
Ephesians two 10 then says, for
meaning like kinda same thing, connected.
We are God's workmanship created in Christ Jesus
for good works, which God prepared beforehand
that we should walk in them
again because of the gospel.
Because you've been made new in Christ.
You have work to do.
But what does that even mean? Like what?
What does he mean by good works? He's prepared for us.
What does it mean to serve sacrificially?
Well, don't overcomplicate it.
It means anything that scripture commands us to do.
It means anything that matches the character of God.
For us, it's anything that is truly loving
and good, that is serving,
that is abounding in the work of the Lord.
Could go through infinite examples,
but just here one, think of orphan care.
There are categories of people in scripture
that are very close to God's heart, widows
and orphans and the outcast,
orphans, vulnerable are close to God's heart.
And so how can we abound in that good work?
Well, one modern way is fostering
that we can meet those needs of the orphans.
Yet here's, here's just a statistic.
In Oklahoma County, our county here,
there are 931 children in foster placements.
But only 524 foster homes.
There's 400 children more than there are homes.
There are also way more children waiting for
adoption than there are adoptive families.
Now the reality is not all of us will get involved directly
like that, but everyone can help.
Here's the truth. Historically,
churches have been strongly against abortion.
But are we going to be as strongly for adoption
as we are as that way?
Like, are we gonna choose life in that sense just as much?
So there's one way orphan care, figure it out James 1 27,
how we can care for the widows
and orphans like that very directly.
And that's close to the heart of God.
It's real religion in that sense.
But then here, here's another thought.
Let's take this even to parenting in general.
What, what are these serving sacrificially great, uh,
good works abounding in the work of the Lord, even
to parenting in it's mother's day.
So let's just think about that for a a second.
I, I think especially moms are tempted to think
that their labor is in vain.
Think of that mom of teenagers
who just feels like every day is a failure
With them.
Or I think of a mom at home with her little kids
and it feels like Groundhog Day.
Whereas just cleaning up and feeding and cleaning up
and feeding and,
and it feels like there's no eternal impact you're actually
making with these little ones
or a single mom feeling completely overwhelmed
and feeling like her kids are missing out
on a lot of things in life.
Or even, I know Mother's Day can be hard in unique ways.
I think of maybe your mom has gone kind
of haywire and you're doing your best to love her well,
but it just doesn't seem like anything is getting
Through.
Listen, any of that
and so much more if it's done in the Lord,
like if you're standing on the power
of the victorious resurrection for his glory
and you're doing it all for that,
then it is not in vain, none of it.
No one else may see that you're doing it.
It's not in vain because it's in the Lord
and it's the good works abounding in those works
for the Lord because of what he's done for you.
Again, that's why we can't forget the problem
that we all have
that on our own in this state.
We are limited. These dying bodies cannot
inherit the kingdom of God.
We can't make it there on our own.
But we can't forget at the same time what God has done.
Lemme just think about this.
The king of the kingdom,
the infinite one took on flesh and blood.
The imperishable one became perishable on our behalf.
The immortal one became mortal on behalf
of the sinner he wanted to save, to absorb the sin
and death that we were deserving.
And he took it on himself instead.
That is why we can remain unswervingly committed
to the truth and we can remain totally dedicated to the work
of the gospel no matter the cost
because God has won already.
And listen, we're gonna get to praise him in a moment.
We're gonna get to sing in light of these truths.
But what a blessing this is, right?
What a blessing this passage is.
Should this not stir something within us
to rejoice, to sing loud,
to speak boldly out there, to live
sacrificially in everything we do
and especially to look forward
to the day he's coming back for us.
Just think about it. Oh, death. Where is your sting?
Oh, death. Where is your victory?
Well, thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.